there's a poll out from edelman it shows
that the american trust in the media is
at an all-time low
as well it should be we shared with
axios here is what the poll found
apparently the trust in traditional
media 46
of americans say they trust traditional
media presumably they are all democrats
among republicans those numbers are
abysmal only 18 percent
of republicans say they believe
journalists after the 2020 election
which
i mean hard to argue with that not sure
why you would
the vast majority of members of the
american public believe that journalists
and reporters are purposely trying to
mislead them
and 58 think news organizations are more
interested in ideology than facts
57 percent of democrats trust the media
shocker
shocker i can't believe it you mean you
trust the media because they tell you
exactly what you want to hear all the
time but don't worry there's no leftist
bias
in the media
apparently republican trust in
traditional media plunged following the
2020 election
but the truth is that that plunge should
have happened much earlier
the the republican belief in the
veracity of the media
it found a 15-point drop in media trust
among trump's trump supporters
apparently about 33 percent of
republicans used to trust the media now
it's only about 18
i'm not sure why anyone trusts the media
to simply be objective they simply are
not
they are not objective in any way shape
or form
and and the proof is in the pudding i
mean every single day i show you clips
of members of your esteemed journalistic
media who are basically just doing dirty
work for the
biden administration or for the
democrats or for the biden campaign
during the campaign
so for example here is cnn's allison
camarada literally asking members of the
biden administration
if they will retaliate against news
networks if they lie
so will here's cnn asking if the biden
administration is going to target
newsmax oann
and fox news yeah definitely i trust cnn
absolutely objective people
no no interest here they are just truth
tellers
by the way that is unconstitutional okay
the the body administration has no power
to involve itself in in
these particular debates here's allison
cameron pushing it anyway
i heard that as a direct shot at some of
the media companies
that lied about the election results
we know who they are i mean they're
they're you know right-wing companies
some are more fringe than others at this
point
or more i guess extreme than others and
so if they continue
to engage in lies something that he is
trying to combat
what is your communication strategy will
you
deny those networks any interviews i
mean
what happens if they re revert to form
immediately
so will you punish will you revert to
form will you tell people that you won't
interview with them
because cnn doesn't like them please
will you do that i mean we are the truth
tellers here at cnn everybody else on
the other side those are not true
tellers
at all cnn is the place you come for
your news and also
for your for your kool-aid from the left
side of the aisle
okay so the the funniest example of this
over the past 24 hours i i thought this
was hilarious so there's a piece here's
the title of the piece it's by margaret
sullivan
margaret sullivan is the media columnist
for the washington post
and she has a piece that is titled i kid
you not the media can be glad for the
biden white house's return to normalcy
but let's not be lulled you know if i
just read you the title
you would think presumably that the
piece is going to say to the media yes
this is more of a return to normalcy
it's not quite as wild and crazy as the
trump years it's not all about the
tweets
but you still have to be watchdogs right
what do you think that's what i mean
that's the title of the piece right the
media can be glad for the biden white
house's return to normalcy but let's not
be lulled
wrong margaret sullivan says
let's not be lulled let's not be lulled
into covering them
with a harsh glare right
i have to read it to you because it is
just so indicative of the mindset of the
media
the media believe they were too hard on
obama too hard on hillary
that's why they got trump and the lesson
of the trump years is not that you
should be aggressive with the white
house in power
the lesson of the trump years is that
you should only be aggressive with
people you disagree with politically
that is what margaret sullivan the media
columnist for the washington post writes
here's here's her take on it you ready
white house press secretary jen sackey
was prepared
she was professional she was
non-combative and she didn't peddle a
whopper of the y
the way sean spicer did on day one four
years ago with his alternative facts
about the supposedly record-breaking
size
of the inaugural crowd the first
official words by president biden's
spokeswoman included truth
and transparency rebuilding trust with
the american people will be central to
our focus the former state department
spokeswoman told a small group of
socially distanced reporters as she
promised to return
to daily briefings in fact wednesday
night's session with reporters the first
of the biden administration
was so normal so weirdly normal that you
could be forgiven for thinking you had
mistakenly
put on an old episode of the west wing
my favorite thing about that is that
she's touting the west wing
as like the way politics should work it
was a fantasy show written by aaron
sorkin on behalf of democrats
that's the way the reality i wish the
reality were just the western yes i'm
sure you do
i'm sure you do the return to norms is
wonderfully welcome after the horrors
of the past four years it's like running
into a friend you haven't seen in four
years wrote columbia university
journalism professor william gruskin
okay so here's where you think that the
article's gonna turn right because
here's what she says it's also
potentially dangerous
okay now here is where you think it's
gonna make the turn here's where you
think she's gonna say yes it's a return
to normal
but we can't be lulled into a false
sense of security we still have to hold
people in power accountable
nope nope that is not what she is going
to say
she is going to say the opposite here we
go
the national press battered by four
years of abuse by the president and by
the incompetence and falsehoods of his
spokespeople is in a precarious position
position
we run the risk of being seduced by an
administration that in many people's
in many cases closely reflects our
values multiculturalism a belief in the
principles of liberal democracy
a kind of wonky idealism so she's openly
admitting by the way the media and biden
are the same right and she says the
commentary from tv broadcasters across
the board all day long
was at times embarrassingly
complimentary maybe that's fine for a
day or two while everyone takes a few
sighs of relief that democracy has
survived its stress test but soon
i'd guess another normal return the
desire to appear combative and to blow
things out of proportion to demonstrate
toughness
she's chiding the media before they do
it
with being too combative with biden
after they basically provided him sexual
favors on the day of the inauguration
that's what margaret sullivan is doing
here she says you know what
you guys we spent the last 48 hours
celebrating with biden
and treating biden with kid gloves and
you know we have to be really careful
here
not to stop treating them with kid
gloves because journalists pride
themselves as margaret sullivan
media columnist for the washington post
on being tough and objective
they like to take an adversarial seeming
approach especially to the party in
power or the candidate with whom they
most identify
and of course actually holding power to
account is the most important job
journalists have
it's what we're here for but there's a
difference between truly holding power
to account
and grandstanding it's the latter that
gave rise to ridiculous dustups like the
one over president barack obama's
wearing of a tan suit
not to mention the vast and shameful
overplaying of the hillary clinton email
scandal during the 2016 campaign
the national media says margaret
sullivan should show toughness but of a
different sort
if they've learned the lessons of the
past four years and i confess i have my
doubts they'll do things differently
they will resist false equivalency for
example
they'll think twice before they put a
reality denying senator like ted cruz or
josh halley on the air
they will clearly call out lies they
will identify racism or white supremacy
by using plain language instead of
euphemism
it's just it's amazing it's just amazing
so the media
have gone into full-blown
full-blown best little whorehouse in
texas mode and margaret sullivan is like
yes but
but could we add some services on top of
that to really make sure that we are
doing our job here you know
the last thing we need is for you to
even pretend to do your job the real
problem here is you're probably gonna
start going soft on republicans that's
probably the big problem here
so let's go harder on republicans and
let's not cover any of the things that
biden i mean like
do you know how in the bubble you have
to be to believe this
these folks have decided before
beforehand in preordained fashion the
biden administration is
transparent wonderful factual and the
biggest risk
is that you will create a false
equivalency between people who disagree
with biden and biden because of course
we all know on an objective level that
biden is wonderful
and amazing and truly spectacular
they're just they're just fanboys they
should just write fan scenes
everything the media write these days
and i think honestly since the obama era
everything that they write is
essentially just in touch magazine
about these folks it's incredible it's
incredible